tutti ragazzi cava che si sta impegnando
il capo comunque non è che nel 2016 anzi
quasi 2017 non ho ancora trovato un
[ __ ] cavo che non ci sia cioè cuffie
wireless
vabbè lasciamo perdere tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono vari geni
ed oggi siano tratti su itunes che tanto
più a livello e le ghostery la mesi
avevo letto un altra roba al posto di
piombino non pensate male leggo sterpa
match ho sputato sullo schermo prima
vedere se scafa un livello decente
almeno stavolta visto con la maglia di
phinet freddi salve ecco veri perché non
c'è perché non bisogna giocare con i
lego bene che tanto si è salvato solo
luke com'è possibile sta cosa determina
la testa dove vai testa dove va il testo
ferma o ti ordino di fermarti se la mia
testa non puoi fare il cazzo vuoi brutta
[ __ ] ti auguro di morire atrocemente
ecco infatti restart chiamo e proviamo a
fare una roba decente magari giorno non
è una bella giornata vero zia è
purtroppo non è colpa mia
vai luke credo che questo sia un livello
più per gli occhi che per me visto che
ci sono i leggo infatti a posto va beh
lasciamo perdere visto che non ci sa che
cosa in soli vello però quando giocate
coi lego fate attenzione
cercate di avere un paracadute dietro
secondo livello sar weil di james stunt
sputerò 18 sorella nancy tu mi fate
mi spiegate come fa questo livello ad
essere secondi in classifica bottle flip
radio flip
pezzo di carne non identificato flip va
bene tra l'altro è rimasto su su su
stacco babel a jean percio sono riuscito
a fare veramente una cosa epica ma
nessuno lo capirà only for ninja forza
viggiano da un finish
mi chiamo li ho visti ma è va beh sì
però stai calmo non li avevo visti mai
arpioni infermi artisti che si va beh
non ci passo mai scusami perfetto bravo
zio non sei neanche ridotto malissimo
no no bravo complimenti mi aspetta forse
ce la faccio forse non posso tipo
passare attraverso il muro non avverrà
se riuscissi a volte però non
prendertela troppo comoda esiti sono
cresciute anche le tette guardali già
fatta ce l'ho fatta melo sucate melo su
non importa sua morte alla fine va bene
al sesso
la trappola questo lo fa deve uscire
prima che cada al tronco
capisco come faccia uscire ce la puoi
fare mai zio pratt è riuscito sempre
comunque una morte meno peggiore di
quella devo aggrapparmi su 11 cia che
hanno capito perfetto per me sono vivo
l'importante questo donum a posto
volevi non sei riuscito mai ma non credo
ci sia altro modo per vincere il suo
livello anche se mi sembra alquanto
strana l'altro quale freddi comunque
vorrei dire ma tanta roba zio the
challenge 3 sarcastica soli al nostro
classico è quello della fatto bene beh
non se sei un pezzo di merda e non sono
sarcastico legami che incredibile dai
frate veramente sono io sono nostro
morto forse se no
mi chiamerò salvato non so come si
dimettesse tipo storto no l'ultimo porca
[ __ ] l'ultima che sfiga ero fatta
praticamente sei metto sforzo funziona
visto come funziona bene per te ecco
trascinati bravo questo volevo
maledizione molto il flip facciamo
quattro film decente questo mi chiese
rimanere in piedi mi trovate in tibet
festeggiare nudo in mutande
no no sulla sedia cosa no vabbè fermi se
ad esso riesca a piazzare questa sopra
va bene è già qualcosa fermi a prova
vedere se riesco a fare c'è qualcosa che
non va
allora stiamo giocando a tira e molla
che cosa stai facendo
cosa vorrebbe dire cioè vale bottiglia
45 gradi valeva una dritta ce la faccio
a tirarla normale una normale porca
[ __ ] per qua bravo bravo questo
volevo
e allora e allora chi è botto il flip
fico e questo basta non ha perfetto io
vinto cioè non ha bisogno di altro va
bene va bene va bene ho vinto io
dottor anno i grassi sono per le persone
grasse io invece sono tutto magro e non
lo posso fare
ecco appunto no sono vivo come dove
lancia no look per grassi questo livello
non per te devo riuscire a fare una roba
decente questi botto rampante questo mai
a fare il botto anche problemi ciò io
col botto grande non mi toccare il culo
figlio sono concentrato bene si sono mi
toccava il culo a questo redivivo brutto
deficiente molto il feedback che è
estremo eh vabbè ed tanto non riesco a
fare neanche lo sapevo fresca farne
anche lets you are a legend if you
lending il suo errato mirato proprio lì
però è andata un'altra parte c'è un tipo
ed ex vabbè non era così ed però come se
non l'ho fatto adesso e bmx rider pro
beh clip quanta proprio bravo michele
lasciato anche tuo figlio hai vinto
tutto per me è un 10 che cura un prato
perché le nuvole sono forma di nike c'è
del simbolo da nike ok ragazzi ve
l'immaginate tipo è più il singolare
quanto dovrebbe essere brutto a posto
mica se faranno mai un ep vishing work
di morire ci avrai un peccato che lo
dovrò giocare comunque vice pres
alta pressione ho capito il problema che
avevo devo evitare che mischia ci di
questi tronchi giganti l'altra questo e
tron chi va a quello che se magna
avevo più pressioni durante le verifiche
di matematica però perché no ma ragazzi
nicchia sono tutto storto io dai zio non
è così difficile
sono ancora vivo sono ancora io vivo io
vinco la pressione io forte io forte io
disse fu premio ti spingono anche la
famiglia non c'è l'età l'ultima poi
basta veramente incredibile non ci posso
proprio riuscire se non la scorsa volta
porca eva quanto sei storto pure tu o mi
chiamò era difficile
no così facendo perfetto l'ultimo
bravo frate così ti voglio liuc ha fatto
questo livello bravo luke ti meriti la
morte prop singh est e smi prima era
mappa e spero che le gusta e spero ke te
gusta l'uccello bene per essere la tua
prima era sma pass non esco swee wah le
small bonita una merda tema tabù da date
sfogo son leo lorenzo è certo se uno si
chiama leo lorenzo non può non essere
porn livello
una male pensavo peggio cosa sta a
significare sta roba che durò poco epic
gabriello co loco e shira stesso e loco
gabriello e loco e tua madre pure ho
fatto troppo ridere quando ha urlato non
so perché mi dai più spalle per cortesia
visto che ho colpito il tizio bene
perfetto porca eva come l'ho centrato
perfetto ok ho vinto mica fontenova
ragazzi pro veramente sono sono un freno
perché faccio schifo in tutto il resto
ma negli world tron me la cavo
abbastanza uccidi o si è ucciso dal
miglior biscotto di sempre complimenti
per il nome zio
secondo me questo livello non merita
neanche di finire votato simulator basta
ho trovato la vita presse space to
gravide potato ok va bene quindi questo
c'è io non ho parole
mi fate capire come mai c'è un potato
vodka la patata e la vodka insieme fanno
un accoppiata fantastica santina mente a
ok devo fare la propria in padella già
fatta sono riuscito a salire
potato michea quanto problematico
superare gli ostacoli con una patata è
brutta la vita a patata dio mio non ho
mai capito nemmeno mai messo nei loro
panni cioè io farei non sondaggio
ragazzi qual è il livello più inutile di
happy vista quando ho iniziato lucarelli
potrebbe essere questo è in realtà
patata hai perso il casco che ti serve
private perché ho perso un karma che
cazzo di cosa sto giocando so che sto
facendo dalla mia vita io spa i folletti
facciamo questo mi ripide un attimo dio
mio
molto buono o 99 per cento posti ma
perché è quello che gli arpioni tre
palle quanto li odio io questi livelli
che due coglie facciamo la petizione
bandiamo questi veli dove gli alpini ti
sparano perché non riesco a farli di
odio
porca [ __ ] o quanto mi sarà il nervoso
di quella [ __ ] laida trottola tana
vacca le 100 persone più influenti del
mondo del times che cazzo me ne frega
niente ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
concluso qui l'episodio vado a mangiarmi
una bella pizza visto che da buy e
salute ogni volta ecco sarà non capito
se è più visti mi fa rincoglionire o se
la luce però mi chiamo racconto cambia
stava smontando tutto ben ragazzi miei
servito era piaciuto consente lasciato
il commento era mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook come nei video totale
descrizione ciò che siete lì ci vediamo
un prossimo video lo veramente preso al
volo che culo beh ragazzi